Another challenge is figuring out where
a specific patient's clinical data
is stored.
Marla, our multiple chronic disease
patient seeing many different
specialists, would have parts of her
records scattered across many EMRs.
Suppose one of them, or
a PCP, should she get one,
wants an integrated view of her care.
Where does it go to
get that information?
Special document locator systems at
some health information exchanges
facilitate this type of query by
indexing where a patient's images,
lab tests, and
other clinical data are stored.
The new Meaningful Use Stage Two VDT
requirements mean that Marla might
create her own integrated record by
obtaining electronic summaries
from each of her providers.
Which of these are reasons for
establishing a health
information exchange?